is also as a civic virtue thinking in
particular photos
but who nevertheless speak to each other
listen to each other and try to
understand each other
generous persons
unlike this is
courageous dialogue does not make
questions
it is
foreign
he lives in the most difficult
situations
Santo
it's a question is
the same letter to the Galatians from
which the reading for this liturgy is
taken speaking questions
benevolent attitudes that sustains and
comfortable
and harshness
or despising
Legend is
several pathologies off
thank you
and so when we meet some kind person on
the street
these are the words
sorry
thank you and I'm sorry
excuse me thank you because
it seems only a small miracle because
something
to
vent
Credit Union
might make a great deal to improve life
communities
[Music]
okay
experience teaches
social relationships
diffusing aggressions
San Pietro
is
the virgin mother
today and tomorrow here in Saint Peter's
Basilica principal tense we can venerate
it
yeah foreign
wanted to be foreign
his kindness so to speak because the way
for a more human world is found in the
Divine motherhood of the virgin
of our Lady our Holy Father refers to
the Madonna of aviliano
it was first brought here in the year
2003 which was the year dedicated to the
Holy Rosary when the priests of aviliano
asked
to receive the the gift that this image
or receive a crown from the Holy Father
Devotion to Our Lady of cardamine and
the community of aviliano and here we
see the image before us that devotion
dates back to about the 17th century but
it's believed that uh an
our lady under this title was venerated
even before that in southern Italy but
became more predominant after the
Council of Trent
but historically the shrine dedicated to
Our Lady of Carmine
1696 built on a hill that rises about
1200 meters
nine kilometers from the town of
aviliano
and it was built into a fulfill a vow
when our lady saved the local population
during an earthquake in 1694.
[Music]
the word was made man Hallelujah
foreign
[Music]